les syndicats cgt cfdt fo et autonome de
la ratp annonce une reconduction de leur
mouvement de grève pour demain attention
donc pour les parisiens et les habitants
l'île de france mais c'est à la sncf que
l'on s'attend à une nouvelle journée
encore pratiquement centre les cheminots
conteste à la fois la mise en cause de
leur régime de retraite et le contrat de
plan que leur entreprise doit passer
avec l'état pour réduire son endettement
considérable et malgré toutes les
avances faites aujourd'hui du côté du
gouvernement une majorité de cheminots
sont sur une ligne du reportage dans un
important centre de la sncf
c'est au mans jacques cardoze nathalie
gay depuis hier 13 heures plus aucun
train ne circule et pour cause il occupe
un point stratégique le poste de
régulation à commande informatisée 200
cheminots sont réunis ici autour des
mêmes revendications
le régime des retraites mais aussi
l'incertitude de l'emploi via le contrat
de plan sncf qui prévoit la suppression
de 6000 kilomètres de lignes régionales
globalement cela sape au risque pour
l'emploi nouveau la sncf puisque la
tenue il ya 500 emplois
aucune assurance sur l'avenir la charge
de travail dans les deux ou trois ans à
venir aussi là dessus aujourd'hui est
clairement aussi vers les usagers
l'actionnaire pour la sncc à défendre
service public
ce que je dois pourtant même territoire
je passe en avant
quant à l'annoncé faite aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement concernant l'effacement
d'une partie de la dette
elle ne satisfait pas ces grévistes
l'état s'est pourtant engagé à reprendre
en deux tranches 37 milliards de francs
sur 175 milliards de la dette globale
par la suite toute amélioration du
résultat d'exploitation sera accompagnée
d'un allègement par l'état sur les
charges financières de la snc antec
milliards pour l'année 96 et après on va
demander aux cheminots de faire
l'économie sur les emplois sur les
salaires d'un milliard pour toucher 1
milliard on répartit du gouvernement
vous trouvez que c'est un accord normal
ça nous on est la sncf
on n'est pas des temps nos droits nos
valeurs on est un service public on
tient à rester service public
ce soir des groupes de manifestants ont
défilé dans les rues du mans pour
certains syndicalistes
il ne s'agit pas d'un coup de colère
passager mais bien d'une action
prolongée
pas question de toucher au statut en
signe de colère
ils sont même allés jusqu'à mur et la
permanence du rpr de la salle